what do we have here a special treat huh
uh
kind of i'm just trying to empty out
any food that might start expiring
i love your bundle of joy and energy you
know that's something what are you gonna
show me show me
mama you're gonna help mama no i'm a
shelter or something
she can't are you showing me that what
is it
show me what you got going on over there
why is there a pillow here huh
are you kidding me duties
okay show me everything
let me turn on the cool lights
that was awesome
good job duty
[Music]
okay ready
[Music]
[Music]
for
you [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa
what's in here
just a sauce what kind of sauce
a green salsa sauce yeah like
chilaquiles or enchiladas and what's
here
oil
uh-huh so what's the next step what
you're gonna do i'm just gonna um what
do you call this
dice roast no
like
fry no not fries onions
uh like warm them up so that like you
have like a nice little oniony flavor
when you're eating your caramelized sure
what's caramelized meat excuse me sorry
where do you when you make it like
caramel
you okay oh yeah what do you make it
chilaquiles oh because we just have
stuff that's just been sitting there
like these chips too yeah um especially
those chips they're super extra hard
chips yeah
so they're gonna be perfect
i'm gonna put eggs
because i love me some runny eggs yeah
yeah yeah yeah and protein
we don't have that much protein so i
made chicken when you were out in
california yeah um and i have a little
bit left over yeah
so i'll put that in there i'll slice it
up a little bit but it's not a lot so
don't be expensive i love mexican food i
always love watching you make mexican
food i don't even make mexican i know
that's why i only love you like three
times in the last eight years or ten
years well i've always been together how
long have we been together for that
too goddamn
that's true
get away from me
ooh la la
la
this is my favorite
look at that pesto chicken
mama you know why this is my favorite
why
because i i think the art of home
cooking isn't trying to replicate what's
at the restaurant but actually taking
leftovers and making the best out that's
our food and then that's why i love home
cooking and even david talks about this
all the time like every time his mom
makes kimchi or whatever yeah yeah it
tastes different every time you're using
different ingredients right so i love
that you use all these leftover scraps
i'm about to throw away and treat me
like an animal this is pesto chicken
yeah and i like how you treat me like an
animal and throw these scraps away that
you won't even feed yourself and give it
to me
i'm just kidding no i love you so much
mama this looks so delicious
i don't know how good it is this would
be really good moment of truth
wait wait
what whoa whoa whoa
um
really good
just really good the pesto adds another
layer yeah
this bomb damn
i'm gonna give it to you guys tonight
i'm gonna do so good because you
deserved it you earned it from me
babe you earned it from me
you look like that
um
what
[Applause]
mexican food
i like your hair why are you doing your
hair like that
yeah it's a weekend i don't know just
for fun yeah that's cute
i mean i'm gonna leave it like this what
i just wanted
the party's over there that is a party
how do you have so much energy little
crazy bones pointing at the wrong you
crazy bones
let me see let me see go
hey monkey yeah and that's exactly why
we're gonna go to foam zone
oh you set that up
i know
you were saving that all day did you
hear what papa said we're gonna go to
foam zone
do you know what that is
yeah because you love doing flips and
falling so we're like why don't we take
you to a place
what
why don't we take it to a place dad you
can do a lot of cool stunts and tricks
and stuff and you know do it safe you
won't get hurt
[Applause]
and that's why we're going to foam
foam zone
hey monkey monkey and that's the reason
we're going to foam zone
see
see why dad stop trying
dad's try they try really hard
but it just doesn't hit sometimes
how dare you talk to me while you air
out your armpits like that you smell
good you should definitely get a
clinical strength secret oh you need
clinical strength
you need clinical strength alright
okay good
hey taika
taika
taika and that's why we're going to foam
zone
stop talking about
them
that's
no that's japanese
but we have been teaching you chinese do
you remember how to say cat in chinese
good job what about dog
what about grandpa
what about grandma
what about car
chica
wow that was a really good pronunciation
what about
apple
pink
good job what about the one we learned
today
friends
i don't know
wow that's really good monkey good job
so proud of you you're learning all
these words
what about your hair how do you say hair
hey good job monkey
well that's jack the channel right whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
you're the
where he goes
and
just because of that we're going to
foam zone
we just can't win
i'm gonna keep trying i'm gonna keep
trying
monkey are you excited
[Music]
yeah you see all kinds of fun stuff
yay
finally it paid off the whole time let's
try to get them excited at all
thaiku is so excited and so happy he's
bouncing off the walls he keeps seeing
all the kids walk by with all their cool
neon shirts and like jumping around over
there
and he's like oh my goodness
taika are you happy
are you excited
you get one too
hey don't don't hit anybody with it
raise bones
okay monkey we're a family
ready to go where's the first place
we're going
there okay let's go mister
okay judy
and the jumbolina good job
okay let me see let me see what you got
it's really hot it's really bouncy
[Applause]
holy crap that's how high
oh cool it's the freestyle zone
look how much money he's having
thank you
[Applause]
good job
oh good job's a move that's cool that's
cool mama
go let's see what you need to do
[Applause]
[Music]
did you have a good time
how many thumbs up do you give it
two thumbs down okay we're not gonna
hey patrick good job dude
your chinese is awesome
dinner time and uh bart's papa requested
that we come back here it's been like
three four weeks in a row he loves this
place because they serve a ton
and
um the portions are awesome the cuts of
meat are awesome it's shabu-shabu and
it's called
swish
so we get the all you can eat here and
it's dope because um like i said the big
cuts of meat unlimited unlimited meat
unlimited veggies they give you two
different appetizers uh and then dessert
at the end of it so
all right so monkey cheeto right here
yeah mark vegeta has been bugging us for
soda all day and we always try to get
him to keep him hydrated and also have
them have like good food first but since
he's been a good boy today we're like
you know for shabwa shop which is a very
nutritious meal we get to have some soda
and this oh my goodness are they picking
a nose that's disgusting don't do that
but look at this guy i love this guy's
face when you drink soda
he's so happy he's the best thing in the
world it's delicious
oh yeah
so when we come here we usually just get
the house rock
it's just like a savory type of broth
once it's popping like this
then i like to just throw all the
veggies in at once
it's kind of hard to do it one day
that's probably the better way to do it
that's my cutie papa
that came here
cause we got the hearing aids
it's a straightforward hearing aids on
blasts
i'd like to do with my ponzu hey that
rhymes it is uh get some green onions
don't go side in them
okay fine
so i like to put my onions in there a
little bit of my
a little bit of garlic right there
oh make a big mess
right there
and then
get this mix it all up
i got extra udon because little monkey
cheeto loves udon
so actually i'll give him that one and
i'll put that in once i take that out
because the last thing you want is a
mixed food armor one's half cooked the
new one's not crunchy
boom oh you can eat meat baby baby
get my protein
i like how they make your big chunks
here too you get a nice little mouthful
put it in there like this
not too much
this is how i like to eat it
almost ready
just like that like that just like this
medium rare
put it in here
put it on the rice so it takes up the
extra
sauce
see this is like the little stew thing
that i make taika that he loves that i
love that he loves was so nutritious
i got a bunch of food on a bunch of
veggies onions zucchini cabbage spinach
meat
all up in here with a little bit of
action a little bit of garlic in there
there's little micronutrients
how's your food delicious delicious
how about that
good i was asking my dad if it's good
he's like yeah it's good it's my dad's
favorite place i was crazy that he
hurt me
oh he's been faking it the whole time
yeah he's been hurt listening and
talking [ __ ]
what a cuny day with the family and with
grandpa
and now
it's time for my favorite part of the
day we go upstairs take a shower watch a
movie so that's what we're gonna do
because 9 30
and i will see you guys
tomorrow
good night
look at that guy's ready already